[Musique]
le constat pour nous c'est que ça on
impact sur sur le vivre ensemble sur la
manière dont les gens peuvent se
rencontrer est sûre en filigrane la
vision de la société qui doit être
propre net secure et surtout pas trop
déranger l'idée c'est que il ya quelques
semaines on était prendre la mesure d'un
bond à la gare de l'ouest qui nous
posait question de par son design
donc on a construit ce que tu vois qui
va en fait s'adapter et donc on va
glisser cette structure mais pour virer
domenech c'est à six plats
[Musique]
si on ne regarde pas en face le fait
qu'on a une augmentation de 50% du
nombre de sans domicile fixe en france
en dix ans et si on ne regarde pas en
face le fait que nous n'avons pas les
réponses suffisantes quantitativement et
qualitativement pour accompagner les
personnes durablement vers une solution
durable en leur offrant des perspectives
au delà des solutions d'urgence
on réglera pas le problème comme on n'a
pas réglé depuis cinq ou dix ans